[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
we showed uh your article that you had
written a bunch of years ago about amber
amber blackmailing johnny
and i remember you connected me to him
on the phone and i talked to him on the
phone yeah we were pretty [ __ ] up yeah
i shouldn't say that there's a subpoena
i was drinking margaritas on the beach
you're in hawaii yeah we were on [ __ ]
johnny depp island i've been drinking
margaritas and i got my wife i'm holding
the fire i'm on the phone with johnny
depp
thompson from the movie
he does that sometimes i think his
monologue may have affected us did you
watch any of the trials i've watched all
the traffic have you so you watched the
part yeah i watched the poop we were
[ __ ] dying like it was a comedy show
when we're watching at the house when
he's saying that she tried to blame
dropping a grumpy
how do you know it wasn't uh a dog feces
how do you know it was
human feces and not your dogs
um
they're a teacup yorkies they weigh
about four pounds each
i've picking i've picked up their fung
before yes fung a word i've never heard
oh my god it's well first of all what
you get out of it is that you know he is
an actor and he's very charming but he's
also clearly a nice guy yeah amber heard
started only fans did you see that
did you really no
he just wouldn't believe it he's
starting a conspiracy right now
what do you think about the verdict
well i think it was probably um good for
all people who believe in the truth
and the problem is there's like this
boys versus girls narrative that i think
we all get into on these things
you know and there's a lot of guys who
wanted a guy to win one of these things
yeah you know yeah yeah but it's just
not good to not be honest
and if you're doing that and you're
doing it to try to hurt someone yeah
like if you're purposely
changing reality you're lying about what
happened just to try to hurt somebody
right you're you're doing a [ __ ] up
thing because you're pretending you're a
victim
and it's so it's not as simple as you're
just lying
you're you're turning someone into a
criminal you're pretending you're a
victim and it's if if it's all not true
if it's all not true
it's a really bad thing it is fun a fake
fake demon we needed i called it i
called it months ago i said we needed a
trial to get us out of this i said
maybe kanye would like kill kim and pete
or something i said we needed a trial
yeah to get us out of the coveted
malaise and it was depp heard and i
didn't even know
uh amber heard breaks down on stan i'm
getting thousands of death threats and
here shed get more
um but you know i said we needed a trial
i was correct we absolutely need a trial
we need trials on every channel we need
uh prank shows on every channel yeah and
we need people inside please don't leave
your house ever yeah at all just watch
this new form of entertainment it's
great because it's like it's like soccer
there's very few commercial breaks it
goes for 20 hours yeah this is the
longest trial that's correct i mean this
shooting will be out of the news in an
hour
this won't even be relevant when it's
released on saturday in two days this
episode won't be there'll be another
shooting by then yeah but this depp
hurting has gone on for as long as i can
remember i think it's six weeks i feel
like i've grown up with these people
yeah i care more about them than i do my
own family yeah and it's not even close
yes i care more about amber hurt and
johnny depp than these kids that got
shot because i've been with them longer
it's just on more it's great yeah and i
mean it's just it's just what it is and
it's the only thing left really that
hasn't been done right it's like uh
trials yeah celebrities that are real
that are drug addicts that beat each
other up yeah for your entertainment and
you know what's fun about it they're
rich so there's butlers and maids and
nannies and assistants and like weird
types of things and there's coachella in
the hills in australia and we're in
we're in italy or whatever they're doing
and they're you know it's fun to hear
about somebody getting beaten
in a nice area it's for once i heard he
is absolutely destroying her
um
i'm too big a johnny depp fan to watch
that i love that guy and i just
i you know
i don't want to hear all this personal
details and [ __ ] but from what i've seen
the guy is [ __ ]
destroying and what's great about this
is if he really does expose this woman
for lying
i'm wondering all of these
people that you know
just accepted her lies about him
if they're going to apologize somehow
because they publicly trashed him it'd
be nice if they then publicly apologized
and said maybe next time we won't jump
to conclusions what i don't understand
is
how do you
write an op-ed about how a guy is
abusive
period
especially if it didn't happen
but period if if you've if one of the
skeletons in your closet is
you [ __ ] in someone's bed on purpose
it's gonna come out
how are you gonna sue someone
if you [ __ ] in their bed
scuna
leak okay
dude
amber heard admitted the poop in her
shared bed with johnny depp
was a horrible practical joke first of
all when you [ __ ]
you don't know if it's gonna be a hard
one or a loose one you know what i mean
like
talk about rolling the dice with your
anus
also
imagine her actually sitting there
i want to know how she did it like
squatting or like on her knees did she
[ __ ] on her feet a little bit or did she
just sit with her legs straight out
or did she [ __ ] and then put it in the
bed
i mean how are you gonna sue someone how
are you going to try and sue someone
for damages
when you [ __ ] in their bed also
when you [ __ ] in your bed when you [ __ ]
in your guys's bed
it's gonna leak you know what they
should do with aquaman two they should
write her in as just a crazy person they
should just make the character so like
she shits in the sea and they're like
why would you do this
why would you do this to me
well she shits in aquaman's bed like she
goes over to his kelp bed and takes a
dump and then blames the dog
blames the dog fish
they should loosely base it all they
should jason memo just starts wearing a
lot of rings you're like what the hell
is wrong with he picks up a conch shell
and throws it at her she he cuts his
finger
[Laughter]
now i'm going to watch aquaman too we
get neptune on a zoom call to say how
batshit crazy she is what pisses me off
is
disney taking away
pirates of the caribbean from him before
the trial right yeah i mean it's like
and now he refuses to ever do it i mean
that's such a great move on his part
though to be like you couldn't pay me
enough money yeah to ever do that role
again which is like i'm the final say in
this smart but whoever pr person told
him to say that right george but there's
it's people just these companies jump
into conclusions
right and they they're i guess they're
pressured into taking a side
right and they make gigantic decisions
based on that pressure
and i just think that's terrible
to do that
you know it's like
you don't you know there's things
something called evidence there's
something called a court of law there's
something called you know i mean
hearing people's point of view or side
of the story or whatnot but it's just
like
you know hopefully those days are slowly
over it really does amaze me
how it just the pendulum just does not
seem to swing the other way
that all of these
women's groups that when they see a
woman that lies like this which really
hurts their position
because there are women out there that
are in a relationship that this woman
evidently
lied and claimed that she was in when
she wasn't and for someone to go out and
lie about it hurts the people that are
actually in it so you think that they
would cover this and they would also
talk about like
you know i remember a guy a long time
ago told me he said if you're in a
relationship with a woman if she ever
starts swinging on you
lock yourself in the bathroom
lock yourself in the bathroom so
you know
she won't hit you anymore it doesn't
escalate and there's going to be no
evidence of you at some point because
you're going to have to get her off you
you know she can be look at this mark in
my wrist when he
you know because you caught her hand as
she was swinging at you you caught her
wrist then you're going to get in
trouble you know you're wearing a ring
it leaves a mark you're just [ __ ]
done you know
it's like no i just grabbed her arms
because she was swinging at me nope we
have to take you in and all of that [ __ ]
um it just fascinates me that when
there's just a clear example of
something like this that i think it
really hurts
feminism if they want
more men to come along than if they
would actually trash
someone like this
publicly the way that they would go
after a toxic guy like someone said that
the the verdict is bad for women i'm
like that's going to say that
that's crazy
it's it's just
not good to do [ __ ] like that do you
think it's pretty some guy beat you up i
don't know
i i could
i you know you watch the trial and you
form your own opinions unless you're
there unless there's direct evidence
and other than the evidence of like the
conversations they had that they were
both recording which is wild
[ __ ] like [ __ ] gotta get [ __ ] up
before you press record without
did they secretly record each other no i
think they i think they both knew so
they both knew
so they decided to have like a
performance conversation
because that's because if you're
recording it you're recording it knowing
someone else is going to listen so
that's not a real conversation like
you're putting on a show yes yeah it's a
it's a reality it's like yes keeping up
with the kardashians knows the camera's
there yeah they know the cameras are
there that's what hollywood is get a
real [ __ ] look at it
that's why guys like me would never ever
make it in hollywood i don't know about
that [ __ ]
dating somebody just to get ahead if you
can't tell that what that was
let them there was no love there
and he don't give a [ __ ] either because
he gets his dicks up 18 times a day this
is something he found the stupid chick
that wanted to move in with him here's
another [ __ ] dummy that wants to move
in with me that's all that is that's all
that guys this is all this is
why do you guys even watch this [ __ ]
support this [ __ ] is what i've been
telling you about years those people
are [ __ ] disgusting
they got no souls they don't like that
shooting should happen in l.a because
those people don't care about their kids
they just have kids to tell people my
kids don't have kids you go to a pool
they go there with that mexican nanny
you go to a restaurant with that mexican
nanny those people don't care about
anybody
they just talk and you fall for it oh
he's so sweet no they're not
that garbage they will sell their mother
for [ __ ] a movie they'll sell their
mother it's like my man [ __ ] by the
way he's got some [ __ ] last week for
being too real ricky gervais i think
it's i don't think either can come out
it's a win because all the all your
private stuff i i don't know i i
i i i i hate having to go through it and
um
it's even weird that they televise a
court case yeah i think that's even so
uh i don't really do that stuff how do
you know if it's gonna be hard or loose
dude also why do you want to do the then
you gotta waddle over to the [ __ ]
bathroom and wipe it dude how weird is
that case over cut cut oh she she
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the bed cut cut case
over
you win how much however how much you
want johnny oh 50 million that's what
you get dude [ __ ] in your bed
the gall
only
a woman dude oh no
a white i'll say a white movie star
woman would do that [ __ ]
like well yeah i'll get i'll win
like to the the sociopathic behavior
dude this case rests on on the first
half of that the sentence the first
sentence of that of that article yeah i
was i was i became the face of domestic
violence the idea was you wrote that and
then you orchestrated
um your follow-up plan to essentially
destroy someone's career and the case
really is the lawyer's case is
we're going to prove that everything you
said is not true
right you're making this stuff up we
don't have there's no pattern of this in
his in his history or anything else all
of a sudden you came along said that i
mean if you listen to those tapes
it's like she's saying i'm i can't help
but i get so mad i can't promise i won't
hit you
yeah i wasn't hitting you johnny i don't
know what my hand i didn't punch you i
was hitting all that big difference so
all of us just go i'm sorry but mo
there's people like why is that why does
the internet hate amber heard well
most of us the people who don't have a
dog in this race
are like i dude i just don't buy it i
don't believe you if this really
goes in the direction that everything
she was saying was absolute [ __ ] and
the level that this guy's career
suffered and the amount of [ __ ] that
happened to him
um
if it all just pans out of with a whole
oh yeah
sorry about that
like that's how it's gonna end it just
it just doesn't [ __ ] seem right and
you know what it doesn't sit well with
me people do not want her in the aquaman
sequel so there are now over three
million signatures among this whole
johnny depp trial summary but people are
saying we do not want her in the aquaman
and the lost kingdom
this petition started back oh god back
in 2020 it's aimed at dc and warner
brothers and people are just saying
please god do not let her do this sequel
the petition should be against the
person that started the petition like
somebody said i'm thinking about
starting a petition to get uh amber
heard out of aquaman
sequel
okay i'll be taking your kids by the way
because obviously you have no priorities
this has become a thing for you like who
starts these who has to petition this
stuff also she's got lawyer fees let her
work i'm sorry you're gonna sue me
i
i'm the one who
you did [ __ ] in my bed right
you did [ __ ] in my [ __ ] chat
like
she [ __ ] in my bed like jack sparrow
just
order order order
uranus was loose in our shared bed
objection he's acting like the character
the judge is like i'll allow it
turns out i like that movie i'll allow
it continue
can you do the scene in the car with
benicio del toro please
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] dude i became a public figure
representing domestic abuse that's where
i believe
it's hinging on you said that you were
abused and then you filed the
restraining order and and i i will say
this if you rest if you file a
restraining order in los angeles you
don't need to go down there personally
with your with your um
uh publicist you don't if you file for
divorce you don't have to go down there
personally you don't do that a lawyer
does that for you a clerk does that for
you
so why was she down there you know
without makeup on that cheek there was
and also if you heard the tmz guy he
goes well
we have to vet who has the copyright for
any video we get and that'll take up to
a day or a week in this case it took 15
minutes because it came from quote
unquote the source that was her well it
came directly from her so i mean that's
what i mean come on
if it took 15 minutes
tmz was like oh well brian and if you
were supposed to believe all women well
yeah except for uh just lane maxwell
the woman from fairness i was just gonna
say
how are you processing this believe all
women how are your categories i have a
big problem with any of that so well any
blanket statement that this can i say
one thing though look at what americans
love this type of like this trial
where's jalen maxwell what happened to
that whole i would rather see that trial
than watch this i hate to be that guy
where's she at now where when the last
time you heard of delaney maxwell yeah
no no i know where she is she the depp
was the one
who wanted the cameras in the courtroom
oh really
she didn't and he knew he's this is
by the way look man that guy's a
nightmare too okay i i don't think he
was i don't think he hit her did i but
that guy spent 30 years high
high and drunk off his
nightmare he was jack sparrow in real
life dressed like a pirate all the time
look if i came in bro with a lace doily
around my head a cowboy hat and 15
bandanas you'd go brian
i take it off right now
defamation case
more like a defecation case
[Music]
you